it's a hundred percent clear that they
had no idea who was who was in that
vehicle and just lit it up hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer freezin TV today we're
talking with Christopher Driskill he's
the attorney for Maggie Carranza and her
mother Emma Hernandez these were the two
women who were shot on Thursday in
Torrance
when the police were on the manhunt for
Christopher Dorner they shot up their
truck because it resembled Christopher
Dorner struck Christopher thanks for
talking to us thanks for having me this
whole event is so unbelievable can you
clear up from the details from yesterday
what happened to Maggie and Emma they
were obviously in search of the suspect
they had a description of the suspect
they had a description of the suspects
vehicle the two women obviously do not
match that description in any way
different race different weight
different height different sex obviously
different clear the make of the car the
model of the car nothing matches and
they opened up on the car I've attempted
to count the number of bullet holes in
the rear of the car I think I've gotten
over 40 but also there were bullet holes
in other vehicles there were bullet
holes in homes nearby and so not only
were the lives of these two women
threatened but also of the individuals
in the neighborhood they definitely were
on edge and I think that the individuals
perhaps wanted to become the hero and
get the bad guy
and I guess that's why we have a phrase
jump the gun they jump the gun they they
open fire on the vehicle without
thinking without regard for police
protocols police procedures and they
it's a miracle that they didn't murder
these two innocent women but they came
pretty close and what what state are
Maggie and Emma in right now well
obviously they're traumatized they're in
a state of shock I don't think that
either one of them
has truly processed this event yet the
71 year old female who was in the ICU
has been medicated she has two bullet
wounds
she has a bullet wound to well to door
back one in the lower right-hand portion
of her back and one in her shoulder do
you think your clients will ever be
properly compensated for their injuries
and damages yeah I'd like to hope so
we'll see what happens
we've dealt with Los Angeles Police
Department before and first of all we
would hope that they do a honest and
thorough investigation of what occurred
and why it occurred and you know really
one of the the main points here is that
this really could have been anyone it
was someone in a truck that didn't match
the truck that they were looking for it
could have been you it could have been
me just someone traveling through the
neighborhood and we obviously need to
make sure that this does not repeat
itself because it's an absolute miracle
that these two women did not die they're
calling it my mistaken identity and by
labeling it as such and having the media
label it as such it isn't this an error
in itself I'm not sure that we can
really call it mistaken identity because
obviously they never made eye contact
they never visualized the two
individuals in the car if they had
obviously it would have been clear that
they did not have the right person is
there a certain mindset that overtakes
cops when they're when they're being
pursued I mean in this case Dorner is
being called the cop killer
I think perhaps they're sort of a an
us-versus-them philosophy that develops
sort of a sort of a war philosophy they
police officers frequently refer to each
other as brothers much like military
personnel and when an officer is injured
or goes down or is threatened the team
mentality I think really steps up and so
you just have that concern that
individual citizens rights are going to
get trampled when the officers are
attempting to get justice for their
brothers what greater message does this
kind of thing send about the LAPD Dorner
was saying I mean his whole manifestos
about police abuse and covering this
stuff up is this kind of ironic I think
there's sort of a triple layer of irony
here where we have an individual who is
complaining about the lack of justice
and use of excessive force within LAPD
and and in order to remedy that he uses
excessive force and murder someone with
no regard for their rights and then in
their attempt to take this person into
custody the LAPD in turn uses excessive
force and unfortunately these two women
are the innocent victims of that
Christopher I thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us no problem
Friesen TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer